- This is something that just
so many people get wrong.
If you follow this advice
it will significantly impact
the quality and professionality
of your PowerPoint presentations.
Hi guys, I'm Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Welcome to another episode in my channel.
This video is an excerpt
of my online course
on creating PowerPoint slide presentations
in the same way as top
management consulting firms
such as BCG, or Bain do.
As you know I worked myself
in one of those firms
for over six years,
I created thousands of PowerPoint slides.
This is really what my work was all about
for the majority of the time.
And I gained very valuable
knowledge and insights
into how to create these presentations.
In most professional jobs,
one of the main reasons to use PowerPoint
is to visualize data and to
present data in one chart.
However, how exactly the data
is presented in the chart,
and what the chart consists
of is very unclear,
and you see very elemental
mistakes being done here.
When you create
presentations in consulting,
well actually any business at
all, there should be one rule.
And this is that you should
be able to take out one page
of your presentation deck,
and that the page itself
should be self-explanatory to everybody
who just picks it up and reads it.
And the reason is that very often
these kinds of presentations are not used
for Steve Job's style keynote
speeches or addresses.
It's not really meant to be presented,
even though of course
sometimes this happens as well.
But very frequently
these kinds of documents
are really used as documents,
that then are shared in the organization,
sometimes saved for many
months and years to come.
And then it is important
that maybe in a year from now
when a new colleague
enters the organization,
picks out a presentation, reads something,
is able to understand what
was meant at the time.
Especially because the employee
who may be created the deck,
or created a specific page,
maybe he's not in the
company anymore at all.
So this is why it's important
that a page speaks for itself,
is self-explanatory, and nobody needs
to be there to really
explain it to somebody,
but you can just understand
it by looking at it.
And this is exactly what
this video will focus on.
We will talk about how to
visualize data in a diagram,
and then specifically how the
diagram should be composed
in order for the diagram
to be self-explanatory.
This video is an excerpt from my course
on CEO level presentations,
on how to create presentations
like top management consulting
firms like BCG or Bain do.
If you're interested to have
a look at the full course,
and read the reviews of what other people
think about the course,
have a look at the video description,
you will find a link to the course.
Actually with a discount
coupon included in it.
Let's jump into it.
Another really crucial concept
when visualizing your data
is the concept of making your
charts speak for themselves.
And what that means is the following:
You really have to think back
about how these presentations,
how these top management presentations
will be going to used.
And the fact is that these presentations
often get sent around
among top management,
or among other apartments,
and then people have your
document in their hand.
And they want to understand
what they see, by themselves,
without you needing to stand next to them
and to take their hand and explain
every little thing to them.
So what's really important
is that you are able
to create your charts,
and I think this is
especially relevant to charts
because charts can often be
confusing to many people.
So it's really important that you are able
to create your charts in a way
that they are self-contained,
speak for themselves,
and contain all the information necessary
that are required for a
good comprehension of them.
So let's just look into some things
which are really crucial
for that to be possible.
So what are the things
that should be included
in every chart?
The first thing is something like
clear description of a chart.
So basically what do I see?
And here's just one example.
So here is a chart
comparing different regions
on a certain kind of metrics.
So the title could be here a bit generic,
Market Dynamics per Region.
And of course try to do it as tangible
and as concrete as possible.
Then what's always important
is the unit of measurement.
So what is actually shown?
And you would be surprised how
many charts exist out there,
presentations that do not even tell you
what the unit of measurement is.
And this chart is a bit complicated
because it has three dimensions.
You have this one axis,
you have this one axis,
and then the bubble itself,
the diameter of the bubble,
is the dimension for itself.
And here of course it's crucial
that you give the unit of measurement
of every single dimension that you use.
So here it says percentage of revenue,
here this is the percentage
of revenue as well,
and here the unit of
measurement is Euro million.
And what I just want to highlight is
whenever you use percentage,
it's always important
to always say the percentage
of what is given here.
And as you can easily see,
if you just talk about operating margin,
so it's more or less clear
that this is some kind of percentage,
but margins are defined
in very different ways.
And it's not always given,
it's not always clear
that a margin is calculated
as a percentage of revenue.
So really make it clear here
that you are referring to revenue.
And the same is of
course true for the CAGR,
for the compounded annual growth rate.
So of course that as a percentage,
but the growth rate of
what are we looking at?
Of the profits, of the revenues,
or what are we talking about?
So always really make clear,
just make it a good habit of yours
that whenever you write percentage,
that you write percentage of something,
and make clear what the something is.
Another thing that's really important
but very often forgotten is the time.
So from when is this data coming from?
What data do I see?
And here it's given the year, 2014.
Here is given the timeframe
of the growth rate we're looking
at, so here only two years.
And this is really important
because it's not really
intuitive what that would be.
Because often these presentations
might be sent around
one or two years later
after you created them,
and then nobody knows anymore
from when the data is.
But even if you create it right now,
and you are basing the data on
some kind of research report,
for instance, that you found somewhere.
In this case it's some
kind of annual report,
so it's not a research report,
but the data is coming from somewhere,
from some kind of source.
And the source is probably
not basically created today,
but in the past.
Sure that you indicate
clearly from when the data is,
so that the audience, or your readers,
they really can know that.
Another important thing is
the legend, or chart key.
So whenever you use some
kind of color coding,
or other things that are
necessary to understand,
use a legend.
And here we're using a
legend for the circles,
to explain that the diameter
of the circles matter,
that they mean something,
diameter based on market size.
And then what you see here
is that these two circles are colored,
so these are blue, whereas
the others are gray.
So here has not included
a legend for that,
you could surely do that.
And the reason why here
has not included a legend
is that it refers to in the title,
that the recommendation on this page
is to focus on these two regions.
So it's kind of logical within
the structure of the page
why these two countries are highlighted.
But of course you could
highlight that here as well.
And then what's always helpful
with these kinds of things
is to include the source.
So where is the data actually coming from?
And often it's some kind of report,
but even if you got the data
from within the company,
for instance you went to
the management accounting department,
and those guys gave you some data sets,
then mention the department
from where the data is from.
This also really helps
to make it transparent.
And often you will have
the discussion in a company
that people are looking
into different data sources.
and one department, the
data looks like this,
the other department the similar
data looks a bit different,
so always make sure
where it's coming from,
so that it's relevant.
And then just the general point,
any other relevant
qualification of the chart,
anything else that is
necessary and is required
to really understand what you're seeing,
put it on the chart.
Because people otherwise might not be able
to understand it any more later.
And just one thing that comes to mind,
what is often done wrongly
in customer surveys
So imagine you conducted
a customer survey,
or you are citing some kind of results
on some kind of customer surveys
that somebody else conducted,
and what's really crucial
with this kind of data
is to include where the
customer survey took place.
So was it a European survey?
Or was it a German survey? (chuckling)
As you probably by now
know from my accent,
I am actually coming from Germany.
Or was it an American survey?
Or was it a global survey?
Because the implication of
the data is very different
if it's a global survey versus a survey
that was conducted in a
very specific country.
And even in consulting
companies like mine,
you would find it
amazing how often you see
customer survey data being sent around
with no clear indication,
even though this of course bad practice,
people forget to write it.
And then it's useless
because you don't really know
where the data is coming from,
where it was collected, and
this really really limits
the things that you can do with it.
And just one small note that
I actually just catch myself,
so here for the operating margin,
it did not have a year information.
So it would be good practice
to include a year as well.
So which year did you take
the operating margin from?
Okay, I hope that's kind of clear,
and I hope that wasn't
too detailed for you.
But I think it's really really
important to get that across
that you just need to make sure
that you put all the
information on your chart
that is required to understand it,
and to let it speak for itself.
Don't let other people
guess what your chart means,
really make it clear for them,
because otherwise people will be confused,
and your analysis won't be so helpful.
Thanks again everybody for watching.
If this video actually
was valuable for you
please press the like button,
and if you would like to keep up to date
with all the content that I have planned
in the next days and weeks,
please subscribe to the channel
and you will be informed.
I have many pieces of video
planned for the future,
both on how to create
PowerPoint slide presentations,
meetings the standards of
strategy consulting firms,
but also on other topics, on business
and management to make--